circa 10.000 anni fa l'uomo ha inventato
l'agricoltura addomesticato piante
animali in determinate aree del mondo e
la mezzaluna fertile è stata una dei
punti più importanti di domesticazione
di piante ha sentito il frumento e di
monte specie animali piante animali
domestica ti hanno poi colonizzato il
mondo seguendo l'espansione
dell'agricoltura e altre vicende umane
conquiste migrazioni e si sono spostate
in zone con degli ambienti agro
climatici molto diversi dal sito di
domesticazione la selezione naturale
i millenni ha reso questi animali adatti
quindi a vivere in condizioni molto
diverse a climi estremi patogeni diversi
terreni diversi alimentazioni a
disposizione diverse e questo creato
l'adattamento degli animali e delle
piante a produrre in condizioni diverse
un esempio
questa capra in marocco una capra
addomesticata sui monti del taurus in
anatolia si è adattata a vivere in
ambienti molto più caldi in marocco e a
cibarsi quando non c'è vegetazione sul
terreno dei frutti di un albero l'albero
dell'argana la parentesi contribuisce
poi a disseminare i semi di questa
pianta
queste soluzioni genetiche che ha
trovato la selezione naturale millenni
sono contenute in razze locali ma queste
razze locali
purtroppo sono a rischio distinzione si
stanno perdendo la fao nel 2015 ha
stimato che circa il terzo delle tutte
le risorse genetiche animali del pianeta
marzo tecnici sono a rischio di
estinzione di un terzo non se ne sa
nulla
e queste sono un
preziosa fonte di adattamento per
l'agricoltura in generale alla selezione
naturale si è integrata dalla
domesticazione in avanti la selezione
dell'uomo prima per gli animali per il
comportamento ma in seguito proprio per
le frecce l'efficienza produttiva dopo
la rivoluzione industriale la capacità
dell'uomo di selezionare di scegliere i
genotipi migliori è aumentata
notevolmente grazie a la crescita anche
di approcci di tipo scientifico e
progressivamente questo ha portato a
quella che conosciamo oggi come
agricoltura intensiva allevamenti
intensivi e agricoltura piante coltivate
in modo industriale queste da un lato
hanno un grande impatto ambientale
lo sappiamo utilizzano energia arature
profonde pesticidi fertilizzanti farmaci
in azienda grande densità di allevamenti
che se non ben condotti possono anche
dare problemi a di benessere animali
d'altra parte hanno permesso di
moltiplicare le produzioni per esempio
per 4 la produzione di latte addirittura
per 10 la produzione del mais in un
secolo ed hanno risposto a delle
dinamiche sociali
dopo la rivoluzione industriale la
popolazione è cresciuta esponenzialmente
s'è radunata nelle città lasciando le
campagne e ha chiesto cibo sempre più
abbondante sicuro ea un prezzo basso e
del risultato la risposta è stata
l'agricoltura industriale un secondo
passo in avanti sulla produttività è
molto recente grazie all'era la
rivoluzione del dna
negli ultimi 10 12 anni 20 anni siamo
riusciti a aumentare la velocità
di lettura del dna che quindi del codice
genetico di piante animali e dell'uomo
in una maniera esponenziale pensate che
se nel 1980 alla velocità poteva essere
paragonata a quella di una lumaca che si
muove a un metro allora quindi una
lumaca che abbastanza lenta quella di
oggi può essere paragonata a un jet
supersonico che si muovo chi vola a
molte migliaia di chilometri all'ora
in modo analogo è diminuito il costo
delle analisi del dna miliardo di
dollari nel 2001 per sequenziare il
primo genoma umano meno di 1.000 dollari
adesso e questo ci ha permesso di
aumentare moltissimo il livello di
enea e quindi anche
comprendere alla biologia per fare un
paragone possiamo dire che siamo passati
da un basso molti molti pochi pixel come
vedete in cui questo quadro si può
pensare di intravedere monnalisa a una
risoluzione molto maggiore e questo ci
ha permesso anche di capire quando
prendevamo degli abbagli
e l'analisi del dna in realtà ci ha
permesso di aumentare l'efficienza della
selezione aumentare l'efficienza
dell'azione vi faccio un esempio un
esempio sul toro da latte
il toro da latte non produce latte
quindi la sua valutazione genetica fino
a cinque anni fa era basata sulla
produzione delle figlie ma le figlie per
produrre latte dovevano aver partorito
per cui in sintesi un toro veniva
valutato quando era nonno è solo da no
non poteva essere scelto per come grande
riproduttore quindi il suo seme essere
sparso nella popolazione oppure scartato
la genomica quindi l'analisi del dna
permette adesso di valutare un toro non
appena nasce non dobbiamo aspettare le
produzioni delle figlie sappiamo
immediatamente guardando il suo dna
se il toro sarà un buon riproduttore
oppure se sarà da scartare
e questo ha accellerato via x 3 la
velocità di selezione dei riproduttori
in questo settore in modo analogo nelle
piante le stesse tecnologie stanno
facendo la stessa cosa quindi abbiamo
aumentato la nostra velocità ma perché
la velocità è importante è sempre più
importante è importante perché ci sono
alcune dinamiche in atto che sono di man
dinamiche rapidissime prima dinamica
aumento esponenziale della popolazione
saremo 10 miliardi nel 2050
la fao ha stimato che avremo bisogno del
70 per cento in più di quello che c'è
adesso di cibo e qui c'è un problema
perché abbiamo a disposizione per la
pelle per l'agricoltura
un miliardo e mezzo di ettari su questo
pianeta ma e non possiamo aumentarli in
modo
significativo dobbiamo magari utilizzare
qualche terra adesso considerato
marginale ma sicuramente non dobbiamo
deforestare cosa fare una una prima cosa
da fare sicuramente diminuire gli
sprechi dal campo fino alla tavola del
consumatore
ma questo non è sufficiente bisogna
essere più efficienti nella produzione
di cibo
su questi ha a disposizione secondo
problemi il riscaldamento globale
la quantità di co2 è in continuo aumento
è il momento esponenziale dalla
rivoluzione industriale a causa
dell'attività umana
l'agricoltura dà un contributo e il
contributo le stime di questo contributo
variano tantissimo separate agli
agricoltori è bassissima separate agli
industriali altissima comunque variano
dal 9 al 25 per cento con meno metà di
questo impatto ambientale dovuto alle
produzioni animali e in particolare le
emissioni di metano da parte dei
ruminanti metano è un gas serra molto
potente ma come un qualunque sia diciamo
questa contributo dell'agricoltura alla
produzione di co2 e questo deve essere
sicuramente mitigato bisogna ridurre
questo impatto aumentando però alla
produttività una bella sfida
e perché bisogna ridurre la produzione
di co2 perché sta aumentando la
temperatura del pianeta sta aumentando
gli scienziati della nasa hanno stimato
che sia circa aumentata di un grado
negli ultimi 100 anni quindi un aumento
molto veloce e come spesso che
sottolineava la necessità di andare
veloci prima per chi non crede ai dati
della nasa ci sono delle prove
circostanziali molto evidenti della
riscaldamento del pianeta
siamo tutti in attesa del prossimo step
quindi ci sarà una crisi alimentare
saremo abbastanza veloci nel produrre di
più inquinando di meno sono due urgenze
beh diciamo che la ricerca sta studiando
nuove tecnologie
una di queste è si chiama gino editing
editare il genoma ed è una nuova
tecnologia che permette di come in un
word processor di cancellare una lettera
del dna e sostituirla con un'altra in
alcuni casi la sostituzione o la combine
o la cancellazione di una sola lettera
può indurre una modifica sostanziale in
un carattere di una pianta di animale
loro di un animale in questo caso per
esempio la cancellazione di una lettera
nel riso rende al riso resistente a una
malattia che si chiama brusone e che di
solito viene combattuta con dei
pesticidi ad alto impatto ambientale
questa mutazione è presente in alcune
varietà quindi quello che fa levitin
essenzialmente riesce a copiare le
soluzioni che sono state trovate dalla
selezione naturale che sono presenti
nelle razze locali e nelle varietà
locali semplicemente le prende e le
copie all'interno delle varietà più
produttive la stessa cosa per l'assenza
di corna dei bovini esiste si sono
popolazioni bovine che non hanno corna e
l'assenza di corna è un carattere
favorevole sia per gli uomini gli
operatori che lavorano in stalla con i
bovini sia per gli animali stessi che si
possono far male e si fanno male per
stabilire delle delle relazioni di
gerarchia
anche in questo caso la mutazione nelle
razze locali è stata presa e copiata
nelle razze più produttive un'altra
novità è che nel topo
l'anno scorso hanno differenziato
spermatozoi da cellule staminali è
abbastanza una per noi maschi insomma un
pugno nello stomaco perché ma perché se
noi prendiamo un embrione femmina
differenziamo gli spermatozoi nasceranno
solo femmine
a questo punto il maschio non sarà più
necessario mi sono quindi immedesimato
abbastanza del pro victor nei poveri
topi comunque diciamo che e mettendo
insieme queste tecnologie
ripensandoci la genomica le
biotecnologie della riproduzione
l'editing cioè copiare soluzioni dalle
razze locali mentre con la genomica da
solo possiamo aumentare di 3 volte la
velocità di selezione con queste sistemi
messi insieme possiamo portare tutto in
laboratorio la selezione che stiamo
facendo in campo la portiamo in
laboratorio e possiamo aumentare la
velocità da 3 x a 30 x 30 x vuol dire
che in cinque anni possiamo rifare
quello che è stato fatto
i 150 anni e questo voglio dire potrebbe
da un lato per metterci anche di
selezionare per caratteri molto
difficile a sezionale quelli di
adattamento all'ambiente quello di un
minore impatto ambientale pensate piante
che possono resistere alla malattie che
possono essere coltivate su terreni
salini che possono resiste la siccità
addirittura che possono avere
un'efficienza sfrutta sintetica
per cui catturare più co2 dall'atmosfera
ridurre gli impatti ambientali o animali
anche questi più resistenti alle
malattie
quindi che usano meno farmaci l'azienda
oppure che inquinano di meno animali che
producono bovini che volevano meno
metano che è una produzione inutile per
loro è dannosa per l'ambiente come
ricercatore devo dire che prima di
arrivare a questo tipo di applicazione
vedono la serie di ostacoli tecnici però
guardando indietro
molti di questi ostacoli sono stati
superati rapidamente negli ultimi 5 10
anni potremmo essere abbastanza veloci
per poter veramente raggiungere questo
difficile obiettivo di aumentare le
produzioni e diminuire la l'impatto
ambientale ma essendo molto diciamo hi
tech molto potenti queste tecnologie
necessarie anche se si apre un dibattito
con la società il compito nostro e di
ricercatori è quello di informare di
trovare soluzioni e di dare informazioni
perché questo dibatto si apra si ha a
cuore aperto senza estremismi per capire
come e quando utilizzare queste
tecnologie e come regolarle nel
frattempo però conserviamo la
biodiversità nel settore agro zootecnico
perché queste soluzioni che noi potremmo
copiare nel futuro saranno
importantissimi per noi e soprattutto
per le generazioni a venire
grazie